papa papa this is the moment you've all
been waiting for of this chair oh that's
right I'm gonna draw from my own mind I
know better than that bro whatever
waiting for her but this started off
with the live stream I I tried to draw
Sonny I try to dress sonic from my
memory it wasn't the best okay but at
least I tried so I want to try and do
that again and draw these cartoon
characters that exist in my mind but
when you put them down on paper it is
surprisingly hard okay it's a lot harder
than it looks so don't judge me here we
freakin go ah Pikachu a classic let's go
I actually used to draw Pikachu a lot
when I was a kid so I have a rough idea
of this bad boy looks like look at this
I know you're amazed already cacao cacao
I know all the details and you gotta get
those cute little furry eyes
[Music]
and you gotta get that sparkle in there
that actually Oh God that actually just
looks like he's missing a soul get that
cute little note how is the mouthful
Pikachu by the way is it like yes it's
colic you I like it this should be the
new Pikachu
how thick is Pikachu this is starting to
look like big chunks all right see he
has his little cute little arms right
he has three fingers Pikachu has three
fingers everyone else's that looks like
an extra pack of skin or something
what's a pack of skin you might ask I
don't know I don't make the rules I just
draw him and I actually practice drawing
Pikachu as a child and his history it
led up to okay yes let's not forget the
tail and the belly now let's color in
this bad boy deviant artists are shaking
right now they know they'll stand no
chance no that's not right
what's the color of belly maybe he
doesn't have a belly all right let's
look at that let's look at the
comparison oh [ __ ] I forgot the cheeks
oh my god no or the cheeks I was
actually proud of it
wait wait let me just draw the cheeks
look at that now it's a Pikachu freak
you okay I don't need your abuse next
Troy minions okay
another yellow creature god damn it's
gonna be hard all right here we go
the shape of the minion is easy because
it's the shape of my peepee then of
course the classic cycle up I all right
so far so good
why is drawing a circle so goddamn hard
yeah I'm happy with that now that's
about it thanks how do they eyes look
like like that like a sirens eye
[Music]
Oh God
what is happening why does he look like
he's about to do something to me I don't
like this how does it how do the arms
look like I feel really uncomfortable
[Music]
I assume they have gloves coz all
cartoons have gloves I Pixar Animation
Studios if you're releasing and if
you're hiring just let me know because
this isn't my minion apparently all
right what is the minion actual it looks
like well that's not oh it's not too bad
right I don't know how you can mess up a
minion no but so apparently they have
hair I didn't know this huh you know you
learn something new every day
incredible banana hilarious thank you
next challenge sands sands from memory
are you crazy
should I try and do the pixel art yeah
space sands this is how a sands was made
you know it's terrifying what have I try
I'll do you justice I'll be you justice
dance I'm sorry did I get anything right
the nose is not too far up at least see
I was wondering if he was chess less and
he is I tried okay I tried handsome
Squidward now that's a challenge that
I'm up for absolutely let's go
Oh God
I know yes like a big chin right
actually trying God you just never know
how incompetent you are until you try
does he had yes cheap I'm not even gonna
finish any further because I just know
oh my god
I need a break
[Music]
mário without a moustache now mario was
another character I like to draw as a
child so maybe this won't be too bad cuz
this is just embarrassing Mario I'm
seeing him a million times but how in
the Frick does he look like he has a big
nose yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
he has a big nose it's all coming I'm
drawing like kids draw when they try and
replicate something that's how my
drawings look like I swear it looks like
a three-year-old did this alright let's
just let's just get it over with let's
let's look at the result oh my god
I forgot to draw the mustache it was
supposed I was supposed to draw Mario
without a mustache and I just forgot to
draw I know technically like it was
supposed to be without a mustache but I
kind of want to see how if it salvages
anything yes yes that's Super Mario
right freaking there heck yeah you're
welcome guys Sonic's live-action design
release yesterday the new Sonic trailer
surely I can't make it look any worse
than it was in that trailer so let's
just freakin do this I think what
freaked everyone out was the fact that
he had human teeth at least that's what
I was bothered by this is something
uneasy about having human teeth
why does it look so creepy I'm trying
I'm scaring myself this happen I'm
trying to draw it what can't I draw
solid egg I don't understand if you're
judging me right now you should try
drawing anything from memory it's really
hard especially these very specific
designs this badly how is this possible
God forgive me what did I get right
nothing
yes years I didn't remember eight years
I got the mouth pretty well to be honest
Sega team if you need help just hit me
up I got you you know you got some harsh
critics but clearly people don't
understand how hard it is to draw a
perfect Sonic I'll do one more one more
because I feel disgusting
okay here we have shrink drawing Shrek
from memory I feel like this should be
if there's one thing that I should be
able to draw from my own memory it's
it's gotta be strict because I have not
looked on a man with any more detail
than I have ever looked at Shrek
I know his ins and outs impeccably as
you can see I am already doing amazing
it's got a very round face now the
question is what is on that face well
he's got a big smile no he's got a got a
big smile right okay okay all right
notes I'm just gonna guess that it's a
big nose I don't really remember this is
like a really cute but this is so cute
oh my God he's adorable
has anyone drawn Shrek this cute I don't
think so buddy he's got these weird
patches on his head too right oh no
we're entering uncanny valley again No
damnit I miss I mess up somewhere oh god
he's so chunky oh oh no no no I'm just
gonna stop thank you guys for watching
me draw out of my memory and thank you
for your wonderful suggestions okay
honestly though was I too far off on the
Shrek like let's skip the torso bit but
I think that's pretty close I think
that's pretty good thank you
ten out of ten Picasso confirmed thanks
for leaving a smash light and always
smile more what you never played to purr
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not convinced yet okay I'll
cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]